johnny depp débarque sur tik tok et
remercie ses fans pour leur soutien lors
de son procès remporté contre son
ex-femme amber heard à tous mes
supporters chéri loyaux et déterminé
nous avons fait ce qui était juste
ensemble et maintenant nous allons
avancer ensemble vous êtes comme depuis
toujours mes employeurs et je ne peux
que vous remercier donc merci vrai ou
faux dans l'univers marvel il existe une
super héroïne femme fontaine qui
s'appelle aqua wons
[Rires]
ne mérite pas tu vas la déconcentrer si
tu l'as notre candidat
l'acteur sait combien les utilisateurs
de ce réseau social ont participé à
donner une bonne image de lui un chiffre
pour s'en rendre compte le hashtag
justice pour johnny depp a généré plus
de 20 milliards de vues
quelqu'un d'autre sur les palourdes
c'est bon mais ça existera plus gros
ça fait passer pour moule oui c'est ça
les moules non c'est la même famille oui
bien sûr
je pense que c'est du croque-notes prépa
impropre mouthe je crois que 8 est un
animal solitaire qui aime se promener
anthropo
n'était pas un peu fofolle mv trop
rigueur j'adore en tous cas comme ça tu
dirais pas l'air elle super intelligente
opale appréciera le on dirait pas ouais
c'est une armée c'est un acteur mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai confondu il
existe à je les ai pas inventés nulle
part non plus à l'est que c'est jamais
entendu ces crédits et c'est moi c'est
une blague c'est toujours comme ça et le
bernabeu
le bernard le bernard mais je connais
pas du tout
j'aime pas ça doit être second acteur
laurent lenne pâtes alimentaires ou
personnes nièce nouilles wifi
[Musique]
farges une tente
[Applaudissements]
on commence à entendre scènes
franchement moi j'ai un petit peu peur
je me détends mais le mec c'est un ouf
et il est choqué les chenilles des jo
[Musique]
ce gâteau la ne lui vaut que des
félicitations
il faut dire qu'à morichon pâtissier
star d'instagram et spécialiste du
trompe-l'oeil s'est surpassé dans sa
dernière réalisation un jeu d'échecs une
fois le plateau terminée et le marbre de
chaque case recrée il faut moulé chaque
pion au chocolat la pâtisserie une fois
terminée et bluffantes de réalisme
on en oublierait presque qu'elle se
mange
ce soir une tombe
il a changé ses bastions alors qu'au
début il était dans un monde de
bisounours il faisait des petits lapins
cette petit lapin est caché dans le
jardin chercher moi coucou coucou je
suis caché sous un joug
et sur son épreuve il éclate de lièvre
qui font sa clio 4 je l'adoré parce que
ça reste mon kisseleva mais ouais t'as
changé au cnes ah non là par contre tu
reviens c'est quoi ça je vois un truc
qui sort du placard déjà ça me fait peur
je n'ai pas su charmer allant mais j'ai
peur pour de vrai de ça je sais pas si
elle fourbit qui exista dessus mais moi
j'aime pas ça
hier la famille entière oh la la la la
la la ça me donne la chair de poule
regardez ça se passe au mexique dans la
ville de cuernavaca qui a une qui
inaugurait un pont suspendu des dizaines
de personnes regardez bien julien
beaucoup de personnes étaient présentes
[Musique]
madoff s'est effondrée
dès peu de blessés graves je précise
quand même donc les personnes sont
tombées deux mètres plus bas quand même
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma visite
l'atom dettes ménagères mais juste un
petit peu elle les germes et mais elle a
des cheveux carrément une chose
mais c'est impossible
d'avancer dans son placard
ah ouais non mais là ça c'est collector
voici la première patate rasta à
dreadlocks
ah ouais c'est vachement tromper là
c'est la wii mais sinon
c'est juste un terrain parce que robles
la série son confort la province on
pouvait pas quitter aussi sans vous
donner des nouvelles de notre invité
surprise d'hier le pigeon le pigeon du
trésor qui a beaucoup fait parler qui
était perché sur un projecteur et bien
rassurez vous il a été retrouvé et il va
retrouver la liberté grâce à des
professionnels qui l'ont capturé en
douceur il est en bonne forme ça n'a pas
été simple parce que le studio et est
très grand et très haut de plafond mais
il va bien et on lui souhaite évidemment
bon vent et on remercie virginie fichier
qui a dirigé les opérations